- So, what are we doing here today?
- We're gonna do a waste characterization
of all of Buzzfeed's trash for a day
for the purpose of figuring out
if there's an opportunities
to reduce waste,
maybe by adding a recycling program,
or expanding on your composting program.
- So, my goal is that Buzzfeed
reduces our total waste by 20%.
Do you think that's realistic?
- We're gonna have to wait and see.
Once we start digging through the trash
and see what the opportunities are.
(energetic music)
- Thank you guys all for volunteering.
Jonathan is our eco expert here.
And he's gonna be telling
us what we're doing.
- So, we're literally gonna be
opening up the bags of
trash, dumping it out,
and trying to separate
it, the material by type.
- What are the different categories
we're going to be sorting into?
- [Jonathan] We're just gonna
do some broad categories.
Cardboard, mixed paper,
which would be like,
office paper, that sort of thing.
Food waste, food soiled paper.
So, maybe like napkins and wrappers.
And then, just kind of a general category
for other recyclables that
we don't need to specify.
- Anything else?
- [Jonathan] Let's have some fun.
- We're just gonna start
digging in trash now?
- Absolutely.
(volunteers cheer)
- Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
(trash clangs)
- Oh.
Any idea what we do with these chip bags?
- Trash.
- Yeah, trash.
'Cause really, they're multilayer.
They're like metal on the inside,
kind of a plastic film on the outside.
So, these would actually
be trash, as well.
And we call it solid waste.
- So, what about this cup?
- Unless it says on it that
it's certified compostable,
all these coffee cups have a
plastic liner on the inside,
so this is actually trash.
- Hey, you guys, hey, you guys.
This goes in the recycling,
glass is 100% recyclable!
- [Woman] Oh, what if we find batteries?
- [Jonathan] Put them aside.
Like, that should go in electric waste.
- I found a whole thing of unopened meat
that says, "Drinks soon?"
So, paper towels is food soiled?
- Food soiled paper, unless
it came out of the bathroom,
then we'll keep it separate.
Hey, guys, we got our first bag to weigh.
We got a seven pound bag of trash.
We only have 193 pounds to go.
The reason why we're separating
the food from the food soiled paper
is because for the purpose of you guys
expanding your composting
program that you have here,
you wouldn't wanna put
any of the paper in it.
You'd wanna put only the food waste.
- So, I took out of the bag a completely
unused pile of paper napkins.
Oh, my God.
- There's more.
- Like, we can actually reuse these.
Right, or no?
(all laugh)
- Oh, my God, you guys throw away
so many aluminum cans in the
trash, and glass bottles.
Do you hear that?
(trash clangs)
- We found some Pero Like
members in the trash, Jonathan.
- [Jonathan] What's it made out of?
- [Woman] It's like a foam core.
- [Jonathan] Trash.
- They unfortunately
go right in the trash.
Sorry, Pero Like.
- [Jonathan] Oh, it's
a heavy one, 20 pounds.
This one is 9.6 pounds.
- We got a new amazing volunteer,
'cause we had so much trash.
- Yeah.
- So, Ryan's coming to help out.
- So, when I was opening up this bag,
I found inside it, many
bags of just bagels
that have looked like they are unused.
So, one bag, two bags, three bags.
Let's see what else, oh, look
it, another bag of bagels.
- Oh, my God, this is all
the food waste so far.
- [Woman] Wow.
- I'm learning that we
could do a lot better.
I feel like people don't think
about what they're throwing
away, they just toss it.
- Come on out, thanks for coming.
Do you want a hug?
- No.
- It smells great, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- So, all of this trash is just half
of the trash that
Buzzfeed makes in one day.
- Oh, wow.
- Just 50%.
(energetic music)
- [Jonathan] Yeah!
(all whooping)
- Good job, everyone.
- Gloves are off (laughs).
- Air high five.
- Thank you!
Thank you, everyone!
- Thank you, everybody.
All right, are you ready for the results
of the waste characterization?
- Yes.
- You wanna guess
what percentage of the
trash was actually trash?
- 50%?
- 36%.
So, about one third of what's in
the trash bin is actually trash.
The other two thirds are
recycling or compost.
- Yikes.
- I counted
about 100 pounds worth of recycling.
140 pounds of compost.
And about 135 pounds of trash.
- So, my goal of reducing
all of Buzzfeed LA's
trash by 20%, do you
think that's possible?
- It's possible.
It might be hard to
gather all the recycling.
But if you were to recycle all the bottles
and cans that are being thrown away.
And then, add or expand
on the compost program
to get all that food
waste out of the trash,
you could definitely beat the 20% goal.
- So, I'm gonna take
you over to facilities
to have you present this information.
And hopefully we can get
all on the same page,
and try to reduce some of
the trash we make here.
- Sounds great.
- Okay, thank you for meeting with us.
Basically, we did a
trash sort this morning.
And Jonathan is gonna tell us the results.
- So, about two thirds of
what was in the trash bin
is actually recyclable or compostable.
- Two thirds of it?
- [Jonathan] Yeah, about two thirds.
- Oh, what a shame.
- But it's a great opportunity
to target some of the items.
The big hitters are a
lot of bottles and cans.
- Absolutely.
- What can we do?
- Interesting, yeah.
- Education.
The first step is putting
a recycle bin with every trash can.
And then, also labeling
specifically what items
that are common at Buzzfeed
that can go in there.
- I haven't given up on my goal
to reduce our waste by 20%.
And I'm gonna be working with facilities
more to make this happen.
- I think it really emphasized to me,
like how much I should be
reducing, and not just recycling.
- It made me realize that
I need to be more conscious
as to where I put, you know, my waste.
Especially, the cans.
- [Woman] Compared to other
waste characterizations
and companies you've
done, how bad is Buzzfeed?
- [Jonathan] You guys have recycle bins.
So, you're doing better
than a lot of businesses
that still don't have recycling at all.